the angels going up against jordan lyles
tonight you see 21 games
on the season five and seven record that
era is just over
five for him this year swats that back
up the middle undeterred by the two
strike count and fletcher's aboard to
start the ball game tonight
one-two pitch from lyles runner goes the
swing of the missile strike three and
the throw down to second
won't be in time fletcher steals second
base that's his sixth steal of the year
on the mound for the angels to make his
fifth starting assignment 23 year old
left-hander jose suarez who is looking
to get a clunker behind him
there's a fastball that he sneaks in for
a strike and he punches out his first
batter of the night tonight
he strikes out his second straight
batter tonight as culberson waves and
misses
well here is garcia getting ready to bet
wow wow
we'll deal with jose iglesias
swinging a miss he gets iglesias
there goes adele throw down to second
base is not in time
boy big jump you can see the speed of
joe adele just a good jump those strides
he gets down there those are long
strides easily gets into
scoring position pick up his first
stolen base it's our first look
at dj peters and he checks swings and
rolls that one right into right field
for a base hit
big strong guy yeah i don't know shrug
emoji he'll take the base hit that's
fantastic right dude make your debut
with your new team and let that be your
first hit you can have a little fun with
it
this one up the middle and that could be
trouble it drops
down and gets past marsh around
third base peters he comes to the plate
and he will score
curtis terry drives in the first round
of the ball game and the rangers on top
one nothing
with going two counts of david fletcher
singled on a two-strike count in the
first
and he does it again here and shohei
ohtani
3-2 runner goes there's a swing and a
miss strike three thrown out a second
oh and fletcher in there
and that one bounces away from trevino
fletcher to third with one gun
on the ground of the shortstop kinder
philippa
road first is not in time and that gets
the angels on the scoreboard
phil gosselin beats out a ground ball to
short which scores a run and it's a 1-1
affair
boy the goose was spreading his wings on
that one
here's the next one on adele and he
swings and lines the ball into left
field and it's out of the reach of eli
white this one's going to go all the way
out to the wall
one run will score another run comes in
and
joe adele is at second base he has a two
run double and the angels have a
two run lead it's now three to one an
advantage for jose
suarez to work with and he gets a chase
out of trevino for his fourth
strike out of the night fletcher now
hits in six of the last eight games
2-2 offering a swing and a miss a rare
strikeout of david mutra
otani leads things off in the angels
half of bending number five
oh missed with location that time and
ohtani sends a rocket into right field
shohei around first on his way into
second
a lead-off double in the angels half of
the fifth
110 miles per hour exit velocity a
slider he tried to go back door
stayed on the inside part of play and
shohei was ready
should gosselin have success keeping the
ending alive
and he will a base hit back up the
middle ohtani will score from
second throw to second on goslin
it's not in time and the angels have
taken a 4-1 lead
or is it in time the rangers are coming
off the field
i don't think he's going to get it still
drives in his second run of the game
suarez doesn't have to throw him a
strike to get him out here 0-2
he does anyway and strikes him out on
three pitches number five for jose
suarez
tonight there's a swing and there's a
drive to left center field that is in
there for a hit for jose
that one is cut off deep in the alley by
marsh trevino's digging for second and
the throw is cut off
a double for jose trevino rangers
trailing 4-1
they're about to have their second
at-bat of the game with a man in scoring
position
got him looking snuck a fastball past
him
that has been the weapon of choice for
jose suarez tonight
now the one two runner goes again this
one lined out towards center field well
struck garcia
can't get to it and it bounces up
against the fence iglesias had to pause
he's now around third here comes the
throw from iglesias
and it's in time and they got him
another outfield assist for adolesce
garcia his second of the ninth
ninth this year so here's jack mayfield
now with the runner at second and two
gone
three doubles mayfield puts a charge in
one that one well hit to left
and captain jack has gone deep that he
needed you back the captain
captain oh captain two run shots halo's
up
six to one here's the pitch there's a
line shot base it
a two hit game for garcia that one down
the line he turns first and he's digging
for second
here comes the throw ahead first dive
he's in there
there's times where you want to see
teams this ball hit well
deep down the left field line it is gone
the bagnes made a great defensive play
and now knocks out a two-run over
following the strike to count to shohei
otani
sharply hit to the shift andy boniez
gets it to first
not in time and not only that low came
off the bag and ohtani's safe
and it'll be phil gosling bases loaded
nobody out
and phil sends that one into right field
it's going to score ohtani easily
the goose has been loose the entire game
with three hits is
driving in another run that's three rbis
balling a strike to joe adele
that's lined into left this time upton
will score an rbi
single for joe his third rbi of the game
and it is eight
three angels
back up the middle fine play by ebonyes
once again but the relay by kiner falefa
skips past
low goslin scores
stassi scores in the state of texas
they're all here in the ballpark
there's a can of him in front of every
seat behind the plate
there's a fly ball out to right stassi
will
tag up and score sure what he learned in
spring in the beginning part of the
season at triple a
[Applause]
and the o2 pitch is swung on and missed
that'll do it sam selman records the
final
outs of the night shohei ohtani has a
couple of hits to get off to schneid and
the angels hang up
big number on the texas rangers with an
11-3 win tonight
you